events like today self-guided study
materials that have
carefully been designed based on
practical assignments for an
immersive experience proven to be
effective for thousands of students
researchers and faculty like you
who have already completed our omics
logic training programs
and thank you elizabeth for sharing
about yourself here now i would like to
invite
elia brodsky our ceo at pine biotic
to take today's session forward over to
you elia
thank you
as biebs mentioned in today's session
we're going to talk about
metagenomics and what i will be talking
to you about
is bioinformatics analysis of
metagenomic sequencing data
so the methods that we'll talk about
today they include
the processing analysis
and visualization of metagenomics data
and so we'll talk a little bit about
some more detailed tutorials that you
will get access to
after this session but today i will just
showcase some examples
and hopefully you'll find them
interesting some of the
approaches that we'll discuss in the
overall program
are processing pipelines including kind
to
data 2 and a popular file
popular package in r called phyloseq but
today we'll see
several examples of how to do those but
also talk about the application why are
we doing what we're doing
and what are some of the interesting
insights that we can get
to understand microbiome and metagenomic
data
but before we begin let's see how
sequencing technology
has changed the way that we can study
microorganisms
and how specific metagenomic or
microbiome data analysis tools
were developed for studying communities
of microbiome of microbial communities
or microbiota
to characterize them in terms of their
diversity
species richness and differences between
different groups of samples which allows
us to ask specific
questions and associate microbial
diversity with health and disease
so since the discovery of the microscope
humans have been learning about
microorganisms that surround us
and we knew that these microorganisms
could potentially be dangerous causing
disease
as the resolution improved we started to
understand
the unseen world that is so much
richer than what we have previously
imagined
the scale of optical resolution today
can reveal details of up to one
micrometer
which is a typical size of a bacteria so
you can actually see
in modern microscopes what these
bacteria look like
these microscopes today are tremendously
powerful allowing us to see
smaller and smaller elements and reveal
how the world of microorganisms
functions
on every imaginable surface and actively
interacting with each other so let's
take a look at
what does that actually look like here
we see
a super high resolution image achieved
with
helium ion technology that shows the
process
of bacteriophages in green attacking
the e coli bacteria which is in blue
so you can see that these bacteria are
covering the surface unevenly they are
of different shapes and sizes
and they constantly interact with these
other
types of bacteria but also viruses
so the connection between disease and
microorganisms that has been established
in the 1800s
has been changing over the years and in
the 19th century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms
in a lab culture were developed helping
characterize them
with staining these studies provided
important information about
bacterial function when studied in
isolation
however it was soon apparent that most
microorganisms
do not live as isolated species but in
fact live
in complex communities many members of
these communities are just impossible to
culture
in isolation so today we know that
the human microbiome or the community of
bacteria that lives within
and on different surfaces of our bodies
are not just unicellular organisms
living alongside each other but instead
they form highly regulated structurally
and
functionally organized communities that
are attached to surfaces as
biofilms and interspecies collaborations
as well as antagonisms that contribute
to
their ecological stability so because of
sequencing technologies
like other omics like sequencing
genomic transcriptomic metagenomic
and other types of omix technologies now
we have enormous databases of data
about such communities and these
databases
allow us to study the data about these
communities
using computational methods and
understand the 99
of uncultivable organisms in the context
of their natural environment so what
kinds of
environments can we actually study
these communities are extremely stable
even on exposed surfaces
like the skin so many of us probably
know of such conditions
like eczema acne or dry skin
forming distinct communities these
microorganisms
are interconnected and determined to
maintain their community so they're very
resistant to change
bacteria within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding to small
diffusible signal molecules
in a process called quorum sensing which
confirms benefit
for host colonization biofilm formation
defense against competitors and
adaptation to changes in the environment
quorum sensing activities and biofilms
are also involved in the virulence and
pathogenic potential of bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacterial
infections
as they enable microorganisms and
biofilms to become more tolerant to host
defenses
and antimicrobial agents so inside each
community
there's this balance of bacteria fungi
and viruses that control species
abundance
and activity so we can study changes
to understand why do they cause specific
conditions
and ask questions about which members of
these communities
are critical for change
but also other places in the human body
contain a lot of diverse but very
defined
microbiota the human microbiota is
estimated to be
around 10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th
of microbial cells with around
one to one microbial cells to human
cells ratio previously was thought that
there's a much greater number of
microorganisms
but these figures have been updated as
late as 2016. so it's a rapidly
developing
field that has adapted to newer studies
that
show what's really going on so these
numbers are derived from the total
bacteria cells in
in the colon the organ that harbors the
densest number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries important functional properties
in genes that contain genomic
information or the recipe to make
proteins that are functional these
properties and the genomic information
about microorganisms
have been of growing interest to the
scientific community
that have been resulting in over eighty
thousand
publications over the years so the
majority of these studies have focused
on the intestinal microbiome but we know
that
other microbiota have been studied well
as well
so since the 1990s microbiome studies
were significantly advanced through such
major initiatives or
large projects as the metagenomics of
the human
intestinal tract and the subsequent
human microbiome project these are huge
studies that involve
many many thousands of samples that have
been made possible through the advances
in
metagenomic sequencing as a result we
now know about
skin lung gut and even brain microbiota
that is starting to be characterized and
we can start studying variation
associated with specific conditions
and disease each new project like this
represents vast opportunities and
challenges to determine
which microorganisms play key roles in
the development of certain
certain environmental conditions needed
for healthy function of human organs
and which can be harmful to it in the
past decade more than
1.7 billion has been spent on human
microbiome research
major projects are today underway in the
united states the european union
china canada ireland south korea and
japan
this investment has confirmed the
importance of the microbiome to human
health
and development so it is now known what
this microbiome function
has to do with let's take a look at some
of these functions
we now know that they contribute to
critical
metabolic physiological and
immunological functions including
differentiation maturation of the host
mucosa and its immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation
metabolic regulation and control of fat
storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function development and regulation of
the immune system and fine tuning of its
reaction pattern
and prevention of invasion and growth of
disease-promoting microorganisms or
colonization resistance so many of these
questions are being answered using next
generation sequencing
but also other technologies like mass
spectroscopy
for proteomic and metabolomic data
indeed the next phase of microbiome
research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets that combine
next-generation sequencing mass spec and
structural data with phenotypic
information
about overall changes in microbial
communities
and the environment that they create so
to understand these challenges
and the changing nature of such data we
need to
look more closely at metagenomic
sequencing data
and ask what kind of information can it
provide
for microbiome studies so let me pause
here for a second and let me ask you
what how many of you are familiar with
metagenomic sequencing data
so how many of you have been
dealing with or have read about or have
maybe even generated and analyzed
metagenomic data so if you have
ample experience with metagenomic data
please put in one
in the chat box if you don't have any
experience
and you don't know about metagenomics at
all please put zero
all right well thank you for your
answers they see that the majority of
you are not so familiar with metagenomic
sequencing
so let's define what is metagenomic
sequencing
and what kind of information does it
provide us with
so metagenomics refers to both a
research technique
and a research field metagenomics or the
field that can be defined
as the genomic analysis of microbial dna
from environmental communities
metagenomics tools
enable the population analysis of
unculturable or previously unknown
microbes
and this is important because only one
to two percent of bacteria can be
cultured in the lab
and the ability to identify microbes
without a priori knowledge
of what sample contains is opening new
doors in disciplines like microbial
ecology virology
microbiology environmental sciences and
biomedical research
so at the foundational level we are
talking about
sequences that define diversity
in the whole population in that
sample so here you can see that as
opposed to genomics and proteomics and
transcriptomics
which focus on the whole of a single
organism
organisms in the microbiome interact
and combine their features their
functional
capabilities as an organ so to say
and so we can look at the whole
community
which is the genetic material that is
sampled directly from the environment
that allows us to study how this
community is divided up into different
species
without needing to isolate them in the
lab
and understand what do they look like as
an
individual when they're in isolation
so there are two major approaches to
metagenomics
we can look at environmental
or culture-free sequencing
and culture free sequencing allows us to
organize
all of the genomic data into operational
taxonomic units
and then look at taxonomic
classification or how
the proportions of different taxonomies
can describe the population
the second approach and many times these
kinds of approaches are combined
is we can extract a particular type of a
bacteria
grow it in a culture in the lab and then
culture based sequencing allows us to
determine how
is the particular member of this
community
different in terms of its genomic
classification
so by the way those of you that are
completely new
to metagenomics i recommend for you
to take a look at our course it's a free
course
called introduction to metagenomics so
let me pause here for a second
and ask all of you to please go to this
link
if you're still not registered on the
edu
t-bio info portal you can register right
now it's a very simple you can register
with your social media or your email
and once you register you will be
getting an introduction
to different types of metagenomic
sequencing basic
overview of the steps to analyze and
extract
taxonomic classification from sequencing
data
and learn a little bit about the
applications
of metagenomics in different domains
like the gut microbiota gut health and
the relationship
between the health of the gut and the
brain
and some of the other applications so
please take a look at this right now
i pasted the link in the chat and once
you have visited
this link please put number one in the
chat box so i know that you've taken a
look and it's floating for you fine
okay in a few minutes we will talk about
some of the other resources that you can
start leveraging for free
to understand more about metagenomics so
please take a look
at this link and once you're there and
you've seen
this course introduction to metagenomics
just put in number one
in the chat box all right excellent
thank you ramon
and uh shraddha anyone else
i'll wait until at least a few people
have uh taken a look
all right thank you dr uh manoharan
okay again this course is free okay
excellent so a lot of you have went
there so you can take a look at some of
the topics that are covered
and please take a look if you're not
familiar at all
with metagenomics it will help you
understand a lot better
how meta-genomic sequencing is going to
be
useful okay so what is metagenomic
sequencing metagenomic sequencing
is typically referring to the 16s
ribosomal rna amplicon sequencing which
is a recently developed technique that
is widely used to study microbiome
directly in its environment
so when we talk about the 16s ribosomal
rna we're actually talking about
the small subunit of the ribosome
that is specific to bacteria because
in bacteria it is 16s in
eukaryotes it is 18s and this
specific gene has to be amplified
using pcr amplification
now that gene contains hypervariable
regions
regions of that gene that are also known
as hvrs or hypervariable regions
provide specific signature sequences
that are very useful for bacterial
identification
by their taxonomic association so the
benefit
of amplification is also related to the
nature of sequencing because
this particular gene is about 1500
nucleotides in length
and so we cannot sequence the whole gene
using short read sequencing like the
illumina my seek
but we can take the hyper variable
regions
maybe one or two of them combine them
together
and then sequence a lot of samples at a
fairly affordable cost so it's a very
cost effective approach
to metagenomic sequencing now once we
have those sequences
we can start clustering the different
types of 16s
hypervariable regions together into
operational taxonomic units we can do
this using hierarchical clustering by
asian clustering or phylogenetic
analysis based on multiple sequence
alignment
once we have those we can organize them
into groups defined
by variation within that taxonomic unit
the taxonomic units could then be
mapped onto a database of these
different sequences to understand
which types of bacteria do they belong
to
or how can we classify them using a
taxonomy now there are several databases
for example the ribosomal database
project or the rdp the silva database
which is one of the most updated and
carefully curated database and there's
also
a green genes more of the environmental
data is in green genes and of course
there's also a whole database of these
sequences on ncbi
so what does mapping on these databases
allow us to do
it allows us to classify the different
types of bacteria that we have to create
a proportion
based on a taxonomic level so here you
can see
classification by phyla and by phi life
we look
this is a fairly low level of
classification
but we can look at how characterize
how to characterize these microbiota and
study
differences between them for example
here you can see
colon that has a lot of proteobacteria
as opposed to skin that is predominantly
is actinobacteria right so we can look
at these kinds of differences
and understand how the different
microbiota or the communities
as a whole are different between each
other
now more than that we can also
ask questions about other members of
this microbiome for example the viral
which is a part of the microbiome for
this kind of analysis we will need to
have a different approach to sequencing
instead of 16s ribosomal rma
we would have to sequence all of the
genetic material
in the sample and then map instead of
the
bacterial database like silva
we would use a database of viral
sequences
and so we can analyze the microbiome for
presence of different bacteria
and there is a specific amplification
technique called
16s amplicon ribosomal
rna metagenomic sequencing or we can
amplify
the viral sequences and study all of the
genetic material and try to understand
whether there's also a presence of
viruses
so we now know that if we include
all of this information there is a
tremendous diversity
that is really hard to comprehend but
using computational
methods we can try piece together this
complex puzzle
and understand how this community
functions
as a whole both protecting our organism
from invaders and intruders keeping
specific species
under control because of the interaction
between these different members of the
microbiome
but also sometimes causing disease or
intolerance and other types of
sensitivities
so it's really about different
approaches to metagenomic sequencing
that allow us to extract different types
of information
now sometimes we are not interested in
just describing the taxonomy and the
diversity in a particular sample
sometimes we are interested in specific
species
that might cause disease for example
uh we can look at specific members of
this
microbial community either extracting
particular types of bacteria or looking
at specific viruses
that are associated with drivers of
disease
now the microbiome oftentimes plays
an important role in suppressing such
diseases as well so let's think about
some project
examples now that you will be able to
analyze
data from so these are the projects from
the public domain
and you can find these projects on
repositories like the ncbi
to really understand how metagenomic
sequencing could be used
to get some practical examples
of analysis so what kinds of data are
out there
so please go with me to ncbi
okay so we go to ncbi
and again once you get to this link
please put in number one so i know that
you're here
so just put in that link go to that link
and i will just search here for
microbiome
and you can do the same
okay so if you can go to ncbi
and just type in microbiome right here
okay please tell me once you find it on
this page
how many bioprojects do you see
on the microbiome
how many what is the number of
bioprojects that you see
that have the word microbiome in them
all right thank you kabir and shredder
10
424 right so there's a lot a lot of data
that you can access from the public
domain
and you can search through some of these
examples just to understand the
diversity
of microbial sequencing data
that you can find in these bio projects
for example role of diet in the
reconstitution of the human gut
microbiome
and its metabolome or
microbial sequencing of compost
or circulating exosomes and gut
microbiome drive
insulin resistance in non-obese mice
exposed to intermittent hypoxia
effects of physical activity so really
we can get
such a diverse range of projects
and ideas just by looking at the
different
available data sets that you can start
thinking about
if you're interested in metagenomic data
analysis
let me introduce you to some of the
important
projects from here that will allow you
to get a great overview of
how metagenomics can be a powerful tool
to understand
the microbial diversity in the human
microbiota
so the first example that we'll talk
about is called
the american gut now the american gut
today
is a component of the human microbiome
project
and it's a huge effort that has
access to sequencing from thousands of
participants
that seeks to characterize what would be
called
healthy microbiome so it was not
designed to target a specific condition
or a disease
it was just open project to allow
anybody a citizen scientist anybody who
wants to
to submit their samples and get
sequencing results
that will allow you to understand how
your microbiome is composed out of which
types of bacteria
but also how does it compare to some
other people
so as a result this is a very rich
collection of data all based on 16s
ribosomal rna sequencing
that allows us to understand
sensitivities the impact of diet
the result of activity different types
of
exercises whether there's a high level
or a low level of exercises different
types of locations
and even ethnic and genetic
background so really a fascinating
collection of data sets
and all of this data could be found on
human food project dot com
forward slash american gut so if you're
interested
in just understanding what types of
questions could i ask
first think about what data is available
and this is a great repository for those
of you that are interested
to understand the human microbiome
this is the place to go and to start
asking those questions
now another fascinating relationship in
the microbiome
is that it has such a profound effect on
the way that we
behave our levels of anxiety
and other types of seemingly unprobable
relationships between the gut
and the brain so this is commonly
referred to as the gut
brain axis and in this project
they looked at the change in the gut
microbiota
in mice through antibiotic treatment
followed by a gavage of
donor stool from other mice and to
determine if significant behavioral
changes
are induced it's a study that was
conducted
based on donor mice that have been
fed a particular diet and then
the donors gave their fecal
samples to recipients and those
recipients
had a diminished diversity in their own
microbiome through
antibiotic treatment and as a result
they were trying to separate the impact
of the diet itself from the
microbiome so in kind of schematic way
you can think about the experiment like
this
you have uh three-month-old males
these males are the donors so they
were fed a specific diet we know that
diet establishes a microbiome
and so that microbiome can be thought of
a microbiome
that has been specifically
representative
of that diet and there are two types of
diets high fat diet
and low fat diet or regular child diet
then you have here recipients these
recipients were prepared
to receive the microbiome samples
by reducing the load of bacteria in
their natural microbiome
so basically they were ready to receive
and establish the same
microbiota that the donors provided
then they were studied for behavioral
testing and so we can compare their
behavior
and what's important is that we can see
the differences in microbiota and
associate these differences with levels
of anxiety
that have been measured through
behavioral testing
now how does this process work how do
you actually
go through the steps of analyzing such
data
let's take a look at an example together
so please go with me to our team info
platform this is a
platform that allows us to analyze data
using a visual
interface and i'll briefly show you an
example pipeline
where you can analyze data from this
project
to understand what are the results
what kind of results are you
anticipating to get from such analysis
so please let me know once you have
reached this site
again it's bio server.t info
once you are there you don't have to
have a login right now if you do that's
great if you don't that's fine
but if you are able to get here please
let me know by putting one
in the chat box
all right excellent great
so beeps is going to put in the chat box
for those of you that don't have an
account she's going to put in some demo
account
information for you to be able to log in
so you can see that i'm logged in i have
my name right here
if you want to have access after we're
done with this session you can just go
to
access and fill out this form and we
will receive that form evaluate your
purpose of
getting access but for now those of you
that don't have access
you don't have an account here are the
details
for you to log in so you would go right
here and would say log in
and you would use the email and the
password
to get access to the demo account
okay so i know that you all put number
one
for those of you that reach this site
after you log in after you log in as the
demo account or as your own account
please put number two
so i know that you're logged in and you
can follow along
doing this little demonstration of this
uh demo pipeline okay so put in number
two
once you have logged in
okay so you can submit but also for now
just put in the email and the password
okay thank you very much so the email
and the password that beeps it just
shared in the chat if you don't have an
account yet
use these details to log in and get
access to this demo pipeline so i see
ramont
has access at or not sorry
has anyone else
okay so ramnath and those of you that
have been able to log in
please take a look at the bottom of this
section called
ngs data if you scroll down to the
bottom you will see here
amplicon16s 18s so this is the section
that we want to go to
and you can actually click on this arrow
that will give you access to the demo
pipeline which means you don't actually
have to upload the data we'll just go
through the steps
so let's take a look at what this looks
like
so here we have what's called the data
to
pipeline this pipeline was designed
specifically
for filtering out some of the common
noise
from the reeds to identify very
accurately
what are the hyper variable regions
grouped together by
operational taxonomic units and then map
them
onto a database called silva
to assign taxonomy and then we'll take a
look at an example here using
phyloseq which is an r package for
visualization
of the data and to do analysis of data
such as alpha and beta diversity
so the way that this works is you can
read as you go through the pipeline
creation process about sequencing
and here are those hypervariable regions
so in this case they used
v4 and v9 so you can see v4 and v9 right
here
those were grouped together you can see
here 16s
ribosomal rna gene pcr amplification of
variable four
regions so v4 and then amplicon pooling
and illumina sequencing
so now you can click on okay and let's
include the data to section so the
bioinformatics workflow here
is focused on accurate sequences because
they play a major role in our ability to
accurately assign taxonomy to the
different
operational taxonomic units and the way
it is done
is by denoising and then
merging these are paired and reads to
cluster
into these operational taxonomic units
and remove chimeric operational
taxonomic units
to assign taxons only to the accurate
sequences now once we have those
sequences
we understand what are these sequences
going to how are they related to each
other so
we can use ape which is a phylogenetic
analysis of those sequence relationships
and based on those sequence
relationships we can build
a understanding of the diversity
richness of the samples and compare them
to each other
okay so if you click on ok click here on
end you can see as a result you will get
some
table outputs for example otus
and their abundance between the samples
as well as what are these otus assigned
to
at different levels of taxonomy
to be able to compare them to each other
okay so for those of you
that have completed this pipeline you
should get
this kind of a set of outputs to give
you an idea
of what you might be getting out from
such analysis
so if you have gotten the results
please put in number three so again
for those of you that have logged in
using the demo account
and have gotten the results put in
number three in the chat box and i'll
pause here a second and just so that you
can see what the pipeline looks like
you can see the pipeline right here
okay strata where are you using the
details that beeps to share
all right great kabir was able to do the
demo
so kabir you can start looking at some
of the results
and please take a look on these filoseek
plots
so this pdf right here you can just
click on it
okay so jin long if you just scroll up
you will see beeps of paste and the
details okay thank you website here she
pasted this again
for those of you that have completed the
pipeline
again you look at this one filoseq
plots.pdf
and you can open that up
just to see what kind of an output are
you going to get
all right so has anyone else except for
kabia
completed this pipeline just give it a
couple more minutes and
here's the pipeline again
okay again for the duration of this
workshop
you have the access to this demo account
so please use it to try to understand
what kind of information are we getting
from this pipeline now
importantly remember that our analysis
is around understanding the differences
between
two different types of diets
grouping those samples together will
allow us to compare them between each
other so you can see
in the results let's think what are
these results
what do they actually mean so here you
have
samples bkf01 zero 2 and 0
3 as well as 13 14 and 15.
so these are high fat diet and these are
ciao regular diet and you can see the
proportion
of their operational taxonomic units
organized by
taxonomy by their family and
comparison between themselves so you can
see for example
that in most of them the biggest
proportion is this orange one
and the orange one is
bacterial dalys so this one
now the second one is this green one
right and so this plot in itself as we
look at this plot
it is a little bit difficult to
understand what exactly
are the proportions and so to be able to
logically approach such challenges this
gives us a
quick snapshot of how to compare them
but it doesn't necessarily
provide us with a very clear
understanding
of what it is that we want to get out of
this
type of information right before we
looked at a pie chart
that was much more easy to interpret
and that's why phyloseq is a useful
package but you really need to get to
know the data itself
and to understand the different types of
analyses you can see here
different types of comparisons alpha
diversity beta diversity
different types of phylogenetic plots so
how do we know
how to modify these plots and extract
the type of information that would be
useful to us
now i'm going to take you to another
resource
that we will be covering in detail in
this program
and that resource as i mentioned this is
a package
in r so this resource allows us to learn
a little bit of r to understand what is
in our data okay so
again bear with me i think at the end of
this process you will really understand
what can you get out of this kind of
metagenomic sequencing data
so please go with me to this link thank
you beeps for
pasting that link again the registration
here is free as well
and we will extensively go through some
exercises
in r during the program that is going to
start in november very soon
so please go here and you can register
so again i'm going to uh you you can
register by uh
get started for free and once you're in
you can go to uh a collection of courses
that are in both python and r and i'll
show you a little bit of how to work
with the
outputs from the data to pipeline so
that you understand
how to build plots based on taxonomic
classification
okay so again for those of you that
reached
code omixlogic.com and
have signed in please let me know
once you're in and you can see the
courses
all right excellent
anyone else
just give here a couple okay robert
great all right so what we want to do
here
is to understand how to
take the outputs from the pipeline and
actually
use r to try to ask questions about well
what's in our samples how do we compare
them
all right so i see a few of you have
signed in let's go to this course called
metagenomics so you're going to the
metagenomics
and you can see here a number of free
courses so we'll go to the second one
visualization of 16s metagenomic data
so by now all of you know what is 16s
metagenomic data
so let's go in here and
you will see what this is all about so
here we have the data sets
from this pipeline that we just did so
this pipeline includes
analysis of uh the otus
and their taxonomic level and here we
have it by
phylum so in excel what we can do is we
can just take the different
phyla that are mentioned in here and the
abundance of this phyla
to then summarize the information
and create a pie chart and that will
give us kind of that same figure that we
already saw before so once you're in
here
just click on next here you have a
description of how
to do this in r okay and
basically it's just a simple function to
create a pie chart
and then you can see that we can also
measure the abundance using
a bar plot and we can do this for
one individual sample
okay so here you just go through the
code create a nice looking chart using
different colors
click on next and now let's try to do
this together so once i'm
in number three try it yourself we're
going to try and do this together right
here
in this little terminal using r
so let's go through this code really
quickly here we have the library
open xlx here you have
uh sorting the table so we load the
table
sort the table and then we create the
percentages
and make a pie chart right so a very
simple script
and also we can create a bar plot but
here you can see that the instructions
say to create using
this data set okay so uh link
here and we just need to replace this
uh little uh word right here so just
delete it
and paste it right here
okay and now we can click this button
run
so it will run and you can see that in
the
console it gives us the answer
and the answer is
proteobacteria 49 bacteria
beats 24 percent from acutes
13 cyanobacteria 6 actinobacteria 4
and fusobacteria 2 and so forth
so now we can see also some of the plots
and we can look at them
either by percentages organized in a pie
chart
or in a bar plot
organized by what is the top so looking
at this chart
what is the dominant uh taxonomy
in this sample by phyla
so what is the dominant phylum in this
sample
what can you say about this graphic
and what is what is that do you see what
is the name of that bacteria
okay it says proteobacteria
okay and you can actually see right here
that number one is proteobacteria and it
constitutes
49 of the sample okay so proteobacteria
let's just take a look at what is this
proteobacteria what does it do
okay so protein bacteria is a major
phylum of gram-negative bacteria
and they include actually a lot of
different types of bacteria
and a lot of these let's see
okay so you can see a little bit that
they're responsible for
nitrogen fixation okay and since this is
in the gut we can say proteobacteria
in the gut and let's let's take a look
at what is this
okay the bacteria
phylum is often misrepresented in these
individuals with e coli being the most
prevalent species
it is clear that a complex interplay
between the host bacterium bacterial
genes is com implicated in the
development of these intestinal diseases
so it actually is indicative
of a common factor in human diseases
and you can see that it is a microbial
signature of dysbiosis
in the gut microbiota so it does have an
important role
in kind of shifting the balance
that should be there in the gut
microbiota
okay so does anyone have any questions
about this
okay if you have any questions please
put them in the chat
now if you look at the overall course
this course includes
some more additional types of lessons
that we will go through
in the course itself by looking at
taxonomic
composition this is a more advanced
course you will see that
we will look at comparison between
exercise
frequency and we will look at much more
complex code that you have to learn
as you are trying to understand what are
the differences between different
samples and you can see here that we
will learn how to create
all of these different charts and make
sure that those charts are
representative of the total percentages
and also compare them between groups so
all of these are
important downstream steps to be able to
ask the question what is the difference
if we identify groups of samples
and how do we know for sure that these
are differences that are statistically
significant
between groups of samples
okay so we have here a brief overview of
the data 2 pipeline and we understood
how sequencing data is processed to
create
an output and then we looked at some
examples of code
in r that allow us to study in detail
some of the variation to understand what
might it mean and start thinking about
the biological implication
now what other types of use cases can we
find
in these publicly domain publicly
available repositories
to be able to ask other interesting
questions well
one important example is shown here
where we can see that the gut microbiota
actually has a significant impact
on different types of conditions and
different types of treatments the
efficacy of treatment and so this idea
of modifying or modulating the
microbiota
has a profound role in how we can think
about
improving efficacy of treatment
diminishing the risk of disease
of developing disease over time improve
the overall sensitivity to different
types of compounds
and protect the individual preventing
diseases from developing
in fact there has been even proposed
treatments
for different types of complex
conditions like for example you can see
here
in 2019 there was an article that china
approved
an alzheimer's treatment that targets
the microbiome so very
interesting development in this field we
also know
that of course many different types of
drugs are metabolized through the
intestines
and so the intestinal composition of the
gut microbiome plays a huge role
in how we can metabolize accurately and
also develop microbial signatures which
are of course
easy to sample from fecal and gut
samples
and so by understanding the microbiome
there's
an opportunity to improve treatment to
improve
outcomes to develop a stronger immunity
and really
change the way that we work with
different treating different conditions
using different types of treatments
so to summarize in this
program we are going to be speaking
about uh different aspects of
metagenomic data analysis
starting on november 17th this online
program is designed to be equally
rewarding for students
and researchers and it's especially
suited for
project-based learning on a flexible
schedule
so we'll cover main aspects of different
types of metagenomic sequencing
different approaches to analysis of
metagenomic data including
whole metagenomic data as well as 16s
ribosomal rna
amplicon data and other aspects of
microbiology research using
bioinformatics
at the end of the program participants
will be conducting independent or group
projects just kind of what we looked at
today
analyzing data from the public domain
and learning from high impact biomedical
publications
on the topic of the microbiome and in a
few minutes
beeps will tell you a little bit more
about the program and how
it is organized now in this program
as in all of our onyx logic programs we
will highlight the role of big omics
data that is shaping modern biomedical
innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision diagnostics
big integration big data integration
machine learning
are transforming personalization of
treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented capabilities with drug
discovery
design and repurposing the various types
of omics data
described in great detail intracellular
and inter cellular processes
associated with common diseases these
datasets can be analyzed to understand
the biology behind
host factors and microbiome composition
in our bodies and the environments that
we live and interact with
to drive infection and cause
deterioration of health
to destabilize the immune system and
lead to clinical manifestation of
disease
now importantly the objective of this
program is to allow you to think
critically about different data sets and
methods of analysis
present your ability to apply
bioinformatics tools to such
data and get feedback both from the
community
the participants of the program but also
experts that have experience
working with such data to guide you on
how to
improve your analysis and the
presentation
now all of our omics logic programs are
designed
to provide students of all backgrounds
with a clear perspective on big data
analytics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence in application to omics
data
and the research clinical and industry
applications
of such methods of analysis and so this
step-by-step process allows you to try
out
many different types of analysis very
quickly
understand the inputs and outputs as
well as
what critical settings in the pipeline
have a huge impact on the outcome and to
test such analyses not on just data sets
that
we are going to provide you with but
also to guide you on how to develop an
independent project
by finding a data set that is
interesting to you
that you would like to analyze and you
would like to interpret for yourself so
we actually will have
whole sessions on how to do that
previously
participants of our previous programs
have led on
to develop poster present presentations
and publications
based on what they have been able to
achieve
in the course of this program so the
program again will start on november
17th
you can find all of the information on
metagenomics.omixlogic.com
and to guide you a little bit through
the different sessions that
we will have i will pass it back to
bipsa
to speak about the schedule and the
registration
thank you elia for that wonderful
overview i will uh start
by sharing my screen here in a minute
and i hope that everybody uh enjoyed
the hands-on session so far
so
what we essentially do with our
omixlogic programs
and i just wanted to give you all an
overview that the goal of our
mixed logic programs is to provide
training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for
data driven research and appreciation of
citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
so together with our collaborators we
have been building this growing online
community of
bioinformaticians in training ranging
from high school students to faculty and
researchers in top universities around
the world
now you are already familiar with these
two platforms that we demonstrated today
and also a few of the other platforms
that we demonstrated
now moving on let me
give you an overview of how to register
for the upcoming program
so let us go together to the website
so elia has shared this link in the chat
thank you elia for sharing the link it's
called metagenomics.omitslogic.com
and once you are here on the site you
will be able to see
a program overview and also the
different
sessions of the program so as you see
here we are starting the program
next tuesday on november 17th
and then the other second session would
be
on november 19th and
we will finish it off on december 15th
so you can go through these different
sessions right here
and you will also be able to see the
different dates if you just scroll
around here
and each of these sessions would be at
10 a.m cst um okay
this is stands for correction it would
be at 9 00 a.m cst which is 8 30 p.m
indian standard time so
to register for the program you can
click on get started and you have
three options this three options
are for the three different levels that
you can apply for
so the beginner covers your access to
all of the resources that
elia discussed today and i will again be
going over very shortly
the intermediate program gives you
access to this resources
plus a one-on-one mentor support where
you will be able to
go beyond these scheduled sessions and
get on a call
with a mentor who will be able to guide
you with your projects or your questions
that you have
while the advanced membership option
gives you
the chance to work on your project for
not just this one month period but
extend it to
another 30 days so it's like a two month
access
to the program and to the platform and
resources
and be able to collaborate and work with
also the research interns who are part
of this bioinformatics community and
part of the
biotech research fellowship program and
work on your own project
so these are the differences between the
three programs but if you are a beginner
you can just start with the beginner
membership because you will not miss out
anything and you will learn a lot from
the program
and once you are registered the first
site that you will have link or access
to
is the organization page so from this
organization
page you will be able to take courses
projects
and also explore the syllabus that is
there
we hope sabila that we are able to do
things for free but
uh these programs these assets and
resources also require
a lot of investment on our part and at
this point of time we hope we are not
able to offer it for free
for everyone but there are a lot of free
resources as elia also showed
and i'm also coming to the next so you
could start by
taking the free courses and utilizing
the free resources
and next year you will have access to
all of the premium
courses on our platform
so it includes both free and premium
courses so you'll have access to them
as well as projects so some of the
projects
that already elia is describing here
will be covered
like the american gut project but then
also there are other projects which we
will be covering
and these also you can do on your own
next you will have access to the t by
info platform
so today the access that we shared with
you on the chat was
a demo access which only allowed to you
you to use the
demo pipelines like we used this one
today
but with the educational access you will
be able to utilize
the full platform you'll be able to
utilize
uh data sets from public domain
repositories like ncbi
and this platform is also available for
research use which many researchers
labs and universities utilize so that is
also available but
this is all included in the pricing
you're not paying an additional fee for
this
and you will also get access to all the
free courses that are available in the
omics logic code playground
as well as the premium courses so there
are some courses on the almonds logic
code playground which are paid
so you will also get access to those
free courses
as well as part of this full one month
training program and if you have any
questions
please let me know and before i pass it
on to dr mohit to take this
session and end today's session i wanted
to
ask you all to do a little bit of
poll for me so i hope
uh can you see this poll on my screen
yeah we can see it on our screen thank
you
yes and if you would please also uh
put in your answers to this poll that
would be great
thank you so much so uh dr mazunder
if you can take over and the poll can
continue running
thank you
uh yeah one second sorry wait we'll make
you co-host
[Music]
um
yep thank you
thank you idia and thank you biepcha so
let me
share my screen
hello everyone my name is mohit mazundar
and i am one of the global
representatives of mind by tech
so in my current role i'm working with
scientists
and researchers and students to assist
with their
omics big data research and
collaborating with universities
to provide support for bioinformatics
training and education
this omixlogic metagenomics program is a
specialized program
that only that not only takes you
through the live sessions
courses example projects but also get
you to learn
by applying this knowledge to a real
metagenomic project
so during the last program we worked
with our participants throughout the
program resulting in more than
numerous independent bioinformatics
research proposals and projects
so these research proposals were then
peer reviewed by experts
some of the research proposals included
analysis of
microbiota analysis of microbial ecology
of the international stream we just see
a black screen
okay so let me share again
can you see it now yeah we can see it
here
yeah we can see it now so
i will not play this uh it's having some
issues
so as i was telling you that uh during
the last program we worked with these
many participants some of them you can
see right here
so the project proposals uh that uh that
were proposed
during the after the end of the live
session
so there's a period where we work with
the participants to work on their
projects
so the project proposals that we got
from these participants i wanted to give
you some examples of those project
proposals
so one of the project proposal was about
microbial ecology
of the international space station and
implications of long-term human missions
to the moon and mars and there was
another interesting proposal
about plant and animal cytogenesis
relationship with task force to
virus toxicity and transm
transmissibility
and how metagenomics can help in this
research
and then another proposal was about
cutaneous microbiome
in patients with solaris so about the
skin disease
so these are some of the projects and
that that i
wanted to just tell you about today
and uh moving on uh about the program
and about the resources
i think uh one of the resources is that
uh we
would also like to also like to
recommend you to visit
our blog where we publish informative
articles related to bioinformatics
resources omix logic training programs
and many more
so this is the link to visit the blog so
this is another resource that
we would recommend you to go to
another important resource that i
thought you would be interesting to
know and if you are interested to learn
about
latest research articles news
job opportunities posted by pharma
companies
and research labs and also about our
upcoming programs then please join our
uh these social media groups to get
regular updates
uh yeah so if
is sharing those links
okay thank you vipsha great so with this
information
uh i would like to thank all of you
including our program
speaker ilya and beepsha for helping
everyone
and we hope that uh you will go through
some of the resources
and links [ __ ] shared today including
the recording of this session
uh which we will be sharing soon and uh
thank you again
for for everyone and uh have a nice week
thank you
there's a question from kabir
all right i read out the question for
you dr mohit uh
did you come across any project or group
working on microbiome in relation to
immunotherapy
working on microbiome in relation to
immunotherapy so india would you like to
answer that
like any project that we have
um yeah so we don't have a
curated project that you can follow
but an easy way to check for
availability of such data
is to just search you remember i shared
with you
ncbi so i can just share my screen here
um so here if you just search for
bioprojects on microbiome and
immunotherapy
you can see a number of projects a lot
of projects
microbiome of patients under
immunotherapy in china
microbial derived enzyme modulates
response to checkpoint inhibitor and
immunotherapy
so there are a lot of projects so if
you're interested in working
on such projects as mohit proposed in
the context of the program that's
actually
oh okay uh sorry do you see my screen
maybe
it wasn't showing before so you can see
if you just search here for microbiome
immunotherapy you will find
a lot of different interesting data sets
there's obviously a lot of publications
you can
do some literature review first but
after you've identified the specific
interest that you have in microbiome and
immunotherapy
here are some data sets and so once you
get access to these data sets you
understand how to analyze this data
you'll be able to be able to ask very
specific questions
and get a sense of you know what's
possible with metagenomic sequencing
does that answer your question
uh elia there is a question from kusal
if there is any correlation between
covet 19 and human microbiome
so as mohit mentioned actually one of
the participants in our previous program
was
interested in that and so here again
covet 19 the interesting factor
potentially would be
how does microbiome
correspond with severity of disease
with risk to develop disease right
susceptibility
so you can see here a number of projects
for example
gut microbiome alterations and
longitudinal kinetics and coca-19
patients
right so again you can look at some of
these data sets to just get a sense of
whether
there's a data set that you can ask
these
questions of and then read a little bit
about
how was the data prepared what is the
data
showing to understand whether what
you're asking
is a reasonable direction right and so
once you've identified that
uh depending on your background and your
um you know different
resources that you might have access to
actually there's
um you know there are a lot of patients
so you could probably generate
uh some of these data sets if you had a
real research project so i think that's
a very
viable and interesting question that you
have there
okay any other questions
all right great well thank you everyone
for joining today and
looking forward to seeing you in the
full program and working together with
you to develop these research
questions and understand how to apply
these tools
so please continue exploring the
resources that we shared with you today
we had a lot of participants that
learned how to do this independently and
we hope the same from all of
you and so we are really excited about
being able to work with you
and mohit as well as harpreet who is one
of our mentors
will be working with you to help you
find the right data sets
to design your analysis questions and
translate them into specific
analyses that you can do
so this is a an informational webinar
that is intended to introduce you to
some of these topics
we provide a certificate based on merit
so
if you participate in all of the
sessions in our upcoming program
and you complete some of the assignments
that are given there
you will get a certificate of
participation or if you
excel and you develop a project of your
own you will actually
get a certificate of excellence and so
uh these certificates come from both
pine biotech and the pi
of the talbot bioinformatics research
center which is a research center at the
university of
uh haifa in israel so we welcome you to
join and get that certificate it will
actually be a valuable certification of
something that you've done
just for participation though you can
definitely
mention their participation in this
webinar
and share with your other contacts
hopefully you found this presentation
interesting so again thank you for
joining today